hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast I'm your host Sean Carroll as
many of you doubtless know in the 1990s
especially near the end of the decade
the very last years of the 20th century
cosmologists began to put together a
picture of the inventory of what our
universe is made of
it's a weird answer that science is
giving us whereby only 5% of the stuff
in the universe by energy is ordinary
matter by which we mean all of the atoms
all the particles we've ever detected in
particle accelerators or any other
experiment that kind of stuff which
includes all the galaxies that you see
all the light that you see from stars
and planets and so forth it all adds up
to only 5% of the stuff in the universe
another 25% to something called dark
matter which we think of some kind of
particle that we just don't see and the
other 70% to something called dark
energy which might be the energy of
empty space itself now I know a lot of
people who are not professional
astronomers or cosmologists this dark
stuff this 95% of the universe seems
like some kind of fudge factor just a
recognition that astronomers don't
understand what the universe is doing
but in fact these are testable
hypotheses and over the last couple
decades astronomers have been increasing
the precision with which we can test and
talk about dark matter in particular to
enormous accuracy so in fact the life of
a real astronomer is not spent thinking
about is there dark matter or isn't
there but we can actually map out where
the dark matter seems to be how its
acting how is interacting with other
kinds of particles both dark matter and
ordinary matter how dark matter can
influence the formation of stars and
galaxies and even more so today's
podcast guest is Lena and naseeb she is
currently I think currently a postdoc
here at Caltech my home institution and
the fall she's gonna start a job at MIT
as a new faculty member there and Lena
specializes in the physics and
astrophysics of dark matter how its
detected and how we map out where it is
in our galaxy knowing where the dark
matter is knowing how much of it there
is
in different parts of space is crucial
if we do eventually want to detect it
and of course that's the goal that we
built a laboratory experiment here where
we can see the Dark Matter directly if
we're able to do that we'll know what it
is but to be able to do that we need to
know how much of it to expect in our
experiments so it's fascinating both
from the particle physics point of view
wondering what the Dark Matter might be
and also from the astrophysics point of
view
thinking about the dynamics of stars and
gas and dust and how they interact with
the dynamics of dark matter so remember
you can support the mindscape podcast on
patreon there's a patreon page you can
find a link on the mindscape web page
and i'd also like to give the occasional
shout out to people who have found other
creative ways to support mindscape
there's a PayPal link and I don't like
the PayPal as much not because it
bothers me but because I don't have any
way to give back if you're a patreon
supporter you get ad free versions of
the podcast and you also get to ask
questions at a monthly AMA if you give
on PayPal you get nothing but my eternal
gratitude so thank you very much for
that I also want to mention in
particular adrian leather 'land who made
a one-time special donation to help
defray the costs of the hosting costs
for mindscape the actual service that
keeps the audio files and sends them to
use you can listen to them let's just
say it's not cheap so I'm extremely
grateful to Adrian for helping out with
that cost I'm extremely grateful to
anyone who listens to the podcast
supports it done in any way it's very
nice when people send a couple bucks my
way but I just like the fact that so
many people are listening to it
especially when we're in the middle of a
sign of a global mess and we have to
stick together in different ways so I
think that this episode is when you're
really going to enjoy let's go
[Music]
lene aniseed welcome to the mindscape
podcast thank you so much for having me
so we're here to talk about dark matter
and we'll get into some of the weeds I
think but let's first a swathe some of
the doubts out there I probably most
listeners the podcast will be willing to
accept the existence of dark matter even
if we don't know what it is but I know
that there are some skeptics as someone
who really devotes their career to
studying dark matter what is the what is
the answer you give when someone says
what is that and why do you think it's
there I always say that it's a very good
question it's one of the most important
physics questions actually currently and
you know for the past sexually about 100
years now so what is there what is dark
matter so basically from in the early
nineteen hundred's
and especially in the 1930s there have
been a lot of studies and trying to
understand how much mass there is out
there based on you know for example the
dynamics of stars like the motion of
galaxies the motion of stars you try to
figure out what is their mass and then
if you kind of do the math you if you
calculate you estimating the mass based
on the stars or the amount of light that
you see versus based on the kinematics
or you know the motion of stars and how
fast they're going you realize that
there is a quite a bit of a discrepancy
there and basically the theory of dark
matter is kind of to try to figure out
what else is missing or how do we fix
this so I think the simplest way to
think about it is that basically the
stars in our galaxy and our galaxy you
know it's a disc spiral galaxy that you
can see in a lot of the pictures but
basically the stars are rotating faster
than you would expect so you would
expect that their rotational velocity is
going to drop as a function of their
distance away from the center of the
galaxy this is basically another way to
say the stars at the edges you expect
them to rotate a lot slower none of the
stars in the center if all the mass that
was there it's just based on you know
the stars that you see but what has been
done in a lot of work
in particular in the work of Vera Rubin
in the 1970s is that stars on the edges
are rotating pretty much at the same
speed those stars closer to the center
which is very bizarre it means that
either you had kind of you have about
two ways to go
you either have to change the laws of
gravity or you have to add that there is
something there that has mass and it's
contributing to the gravity of your
system and of your galaxy but you just
can't see it and these are like the two
major trains of thought here okay so
what if what is to stop me from saying
that it's just something we don't
understand about gravity after all
gravity is very weak and we're talking
about the size of a galaxy we've never
been there we've never visited distances
that far away that's right and so there
it's not just if you only have the
dynamics right you can actually build
and some people did build you know
McGehee some theory of gravity that
would explain these kind of destroyed
these kind of distributions and these
changes however there are a lot of other
things that we need to take into account
so your theory has to explain slash
predict multiple observe observe ations
or observables for example one of them
is basically the power spectrum of the
Cosmic Microwave Background which is a
lot it is a lot but basically what
happened is that so if we kind of go
back into a brief history of time the
universe started very very hot and then
as universe expanded it was cooling so
we were forming more and more bound
States and as we were doing that at some
point all the a lot of the electrons are
all the electrons actually bounden with
protons to become hydrogen and then the
universe was kind of like all of a
sudden neutral which means that light
can go through without hitting anything
you if the electrons and the protons are
all over the place and whatever if you
have light it will kind of get absorbed
and if and it will get absorbed by all
of these particles anyways
so basically at about 300,000 years
after the Big Bang after the beginning
of the universe there
was light and interestingly enough it is
light that we can actually detect now
interestingly its imprints or like its
properties and you know the fluctuations
in that what we call the cosmic
microwave background or CMB really tells
us about the initial structures and this
is one one of the most precise
measurements that we have in modern
astronomy astrophysics actually these
are these famous pictures we see right
alike the ellipse with the green and red
colors etc of the background that's
right yes so it's so the interesting
thing that we can get out of the CMB is
basically how the origin of matter and
galaxies and basically the original size
of the galaxy so the so one thing that
you know a theory of dark matter does
explain quite well is how much amount
like what is the amount of dark matter
that we can see there that was initially
that is not out of the you know the
matter budget of the things that were
made of so said it said differently uh
we know because of this very precise
measurement we know that 84% of the
matter budget of the universe is made
it's part of this dark matter that we
just that is different from you know the
cinema different from electrons
different from protons different from
what makes the Stars and our iPhones and
all of the stuff that we already know so
it has to be something there that kind
of measurement is a little bit difficult
to make up just with a theory and with a
new theory of gravity and that's why
well that's why I work on dark matter
but yeah so what I'm trying to say is
that there are a lot of other
observables the CMB is just one of them
that kind of push for more of this
theory that there is something else that
is there yeah no I completely agree and
I think that a lot of people who are
dark matter skeptics are a little bit
stuck in the 1980s thinking that all
they have to do is to explain the
rotation curves of spiral galaxies and
they can declare victory over dark
matter but these days there's a lot more
data from a lot of completely different
sources that points in exactly the same
direction absolutely exactly so I think
there are there are a lot of these
wonderful reviews that kind of and they
have been - a talk that actually kind of
numbered them and there were I think 14
different observables that the speaker
was mentioning all from these different
mechanisms at different scales
you know from galaxy clusters to smaller
galaxies to just the Milky Way etc that
you know that kind of all point into a
direction that ever is there is a new
particle there is something there maybe
it doesn't doesn't have to be like a
particle particle but there is some new
species of matter that we call dark
matter now and that can explain all of
this
yeah the the point here is it's not just
some stars that are dark or you know
some planets or something like that we
have reason to believe that it's a
different kind of thing is that right
that's right so we so whatever it is it
has very small probability to interact
with the standard model is made out of
different things there has been a lot of
these theories about yes being exactly
that like being dim stars and these
ended up being called macho's which
stands for massive massive compact halo
objects thank you Matros so there are a
lot of these experiments that actually
ruled out different scales of matches
and that kind of tells us that it's
really it's not just some object that is
just a star that is just way too dim and
we can't see it that companies for the
mass yeah it's something else but it
could be black holes right yes so it
could be primordial black holes uh there
has been a lot of work especially
recently I'm trying to understand what
is the possibility or like what is the
parameter space so it is the theory of
primordial black holes explaining dark
matter is still possible there is some
disagreement within the community of how
much of it
ruled out it's not the theory is not
completely ruled out but quite a few
chunks of it are so it yeah it depends
on the measurements and there are some
like very small windows for example I
think 15 to 30 solar masses is still
possible something like that so yeah so
it is not a completely ruled out theory
it also could be or this is even more
possible that primordial black holes
would make up a fraction or what we call
dark matter and then the rest of
something else
so I mean the way that we think about
dark matter of course you have to think
about the simplest thing first you think
it's the one thing but honestly it could
be a composite set of things right for
in the 80s we thought it was neutrinos
hmm neutrinos III no physicist who just
who says like come on people we have to
say that neutrinos are a part of the
best matter they're dark exactly
it's just that they're a very small
fraction they cannot explain all the
dark matter that we have so well yeah
we're sort of we're working away
backwards from the weirdest theories to
the most popular ones
so modifying gravity by itself doesn't
work I mean gravity might be different
right on cosmic scales but it's not
enough to explain all of the data that
the dark matter does black holes you're
saying you seem to be saying if I can
summarize it that if there is some
mechanism for making black holes early
on they could be some of the dark matter
but it's hard to make them be all of it
is that fair that's right it's much more
difficult to make them pure like to make
them all completely the dark matter it
could be a small fraction that has not
be rolled out and what kind of
experiments I mean how would you know
how do you how do you test that so a lot
of these experiments for looking for
primordial black holes are basically
based losing gravitational lensing on
different scales so so gravitational
lensing is basically that if you have
something very very masses between you
and you know an object that actually
emits a lot of light then the light is
going to
get bent in one in different ways so you
what you see in the sky are like these
beautiful rings or anything rings that
tell you that there is a mass so there
are different like a variety of
gravitational lensing of on different
scales like weak lensing microlensing
etcetera so these or at least part of
them part of these methods are used to
try to determine how if there are a lot
of these primordial black holes or these
black holes around so for example you
you know how much dark matter there
should be and so for each mass range of
you know black holes you would just to
make how the number that you would see
and then you would kind of scan the sky
and try to study the motion in the Stars
and try to see if there if there is this
lensing because they statistically based
on the number that you would expect you
would you would have to see some of
these kind of some of these rings and
some of these evidence for weak lensing
and Sarah so when you don't see that you
can put a bound on a specific mass and a
specific fraction of these black holes
so if the dark matter in other words
were little tiny subatomic particles
they'd be kind of distributed smoothly
and they wouldn't cause a lot of these
lensing events but if you lump a bunch
of dark matter into a black hole it can
sort of have a bigger impact now and
again and you would notice it that's
exactly right so if your so if your dark
matter is made out of particles you have
to kind of adjust and have different
ways of detecting it versus if it was
black hole thing you can you know use
these methods of weak lensing so for
particles for example there are three
major kind of methods or detection
experiments that that it has been that
we've been looking into colliders direct
detection and indirect detection and I'm
happy to gonna go through these yeah I'm
so sorry let's just catch our breath so
the the the point is that most working
astrophysicists or cosmologists think
that not only is there Dark Matter but
it's something that's not in the
standard model of particle physics
you never found here on earth and it's
some kind of particle it's probably not
all just black holes so the question is
how could we test this kind of idea
experimentally and in the interesting
thing is that for different Mouse
regions of whatever this particle is in
different directions you have to you
have to have a slightly different set of
experiments so basically a lot each one
of your experiments is going to be
sensitive to some part of the parameter
space that oh the or dark matter the
dark matter parameter space is huge I
somewhere between forty and seventy two
orders of magnitude what what do we mean
by the parameter space of the dark
matter no so basically what is so
imagine that you have this you're trying
to discover this object whatever it is
and you're assuming it's a pump it's
somewhere between a particle in black
hole and the one I'm talking about
parameter space you want to understand
the one of the bigger question is what
is its mass what is the mass of this
object because the mass is going to tell
you about how much of it there is
because you already know the mass
density basically and and then when you
figure out its mass you have to
understand how it interacts with
everything else does it talk what we
call talk to the standard model or it
doesn't interact with it or is it just
going through us and and basically we're
completely invisible to it we know
already that it has extremely weak
interaction with the standard model but
is it weak or is it zero right both of
these are possibility and we know it's
weak just because we would have noticed
it already seen it already yep let me
pause for a second to talk about the
great courses plus a streaming service
that gives you access to a large variety
of courses taught by some of the best
professors out there from serious stuff
from history science literature to
learning new hobbies you can learn to
play guitar perform magic tricks one of
the great things about the great courses
plus is you can watch from your mobile
device or on your TV at home
you can sit around with the family with
your kids and learn new things
I myself have taught several courses
with the great courses relevant to
today's episode I taught a course on
dark matter and dark energy so if you
want the bigger picture of the stuff
we're talking about today check out that
course and learn about the basics of
modern cosmology and now is the great
time to start because the great courses
plus is giving mindscape listeners a
special offer free trial with unlimited
access to the entire library to get
started go to the great courses plus
comm slash mindscape that's th e great
courses PLU s calm slash mind scape
start your free trial today
so I guess does it make sense to first
met why don't we why don't we mention
some candidates or what the dark matter
could be just so our listeners minds
have tuned to well how would we go look
for these particular ideas yes so one of
the most common ideas has been what we
call wins for weakly interacting massive
particle so wimps would end up being in
the mass of 1 to 100 GeV so that
translates to somewhere between the mass
of a proton to a massive I think gold
atoms and this is just one particle that
is you know the that makes up all of the
dark matter it's just one very simple
particle and it has some small
interaction with the Santa model and it
is in that one particular mass range the
reason that the mass range was
particularly you know appealing from a
theoretical point of view is that it
would have it would have had some
relation with with the weak force in the
standard model but basically that is
kind of the simplest idea really that
you could come up with and ergo it's
very popular because it's much easier to
test so for example that would be one of
these of course the primordial black
holes that we discussed earlier is also
one of the candidates you can also think
of of accion's or exhale like particles
I these particles basically can play a
role and how in how you know the quarks
get mass and there there is a hole
basically they are motivated by
theoretical theoretical needs and then
they happen to be naturally very good
candidates for dark matter as well so
and this is very attractive for me
because this point of view because if
you have a theory that kind of fixes a
lot like addresses many problems yeah
those two problems at once
exactly so atoms do that yeah yeah and
uh and they tend to be a lot lighter
than the wimps that I was talking about
so accion's well the QCD accion's over
like the the exhales that people think
about are going to be ending up
somewhere in the ten to the minus six
electron volts which is basically about
trying to figure it out okay ten
thousand times lighter than a neutrino
which I'm not sure he's gonna say
anything by I think we can say yeah ten
to the minus six electron volts for an
accion whereas a proton is ten to the
plus nine electron volts so there's 15
orders of magnitude in between exactly
so you can see that already that's the
different theories of dark matter have a
while different masses actually the
lightest mass that you can actually
think of that is possible to be dark
matter is a regime that we call fuzzy
dark matter and it is basically the
smallest masses 10 to the minus 22
electron volt so something even smaller
right uh yes so there are a lot of
beautiful theories and then the question
is how can we find them do we take
neutrinos seriously are there weird
versions of neutrinos that could be the
dark matter
um so there are there are serious
searches for not our neutrino our three
neutrinos are fine but if
there is a sterile neutrino forth
neutrino it could have like a very high
mass because then you would try to solve
the problem of neutrino masses which is
a bit different so in brief the theory
we have this theory of standard model
that kind of tells us about the
particles that we are made of and their
interactions and it is a very very
successful theory and it kind of it's
upsetting how successful it is point of
view because we want it to fail so you
can figure out what else is missing and
but one of the things that it doesn't
address is neutrino masses so trying to
figure out how you can give neutrinos
masses and maybe sort that out into you
know the whole world of dark matter that
is also a possibility okay so so we have
besides the black holes we have wimps
which someone just invented right
they're not in the standard model there
are extra particles that that would be
fun to have accion's which were also
invented for another reason to solve
other problems in the standard model
neutrinos which we actually know about
but the ones that we know about can't be
the dark matter because we know how
heavy they are and they don't have the
right masses so you need to invent a
different kind of neutrino exactly
they're a bit too hot which means that
they are going way too fast for their
mass and having them being that hot like
basically they're from their mouths and
their interactions they would if they
were all the Dark Matter they would have
destroyed a lot of the structure that we
see is just because you know you can
imagine that you have a clump of
something and then the neutrinos aren't
going so fast through it they're they
just break it apart so I would not make
a good theory of dark matter because the
world is definitely not broken apart
well this is but this is also you know
just a crucial thing to appreciate in
terms of how the signs of Dark Matter
works you know because there are a
tremendous number of constraints it's
not just like oh there's some dark stuff
it's mysterious we don't know what it is
maybe it's quantum mechanics or
something like that it's there's very
very specific properties this better
have and if you do something simple like
make its mass too low
so that it's too high temperature and
fast then everything breaks and it's not
a good theory anymore
absolutely and and it's funny because I
mean as a grad student a couple of my
earlier projects where to kind of build
a new theory of dark matter and trust me
it's a lot harder than it's at there are
a lot of constraints and whatever Theory
you can come up with has to actually you
know has to not be ruled out by the
existing experiments which actually rely
quite a lot so yes and we don't know
enough that's true
but we know what it's not in a lot of
different ways and I think that it's
gonna it's it's more of a detective work
which i think is really fun and you try
to kind of piece it up together because
whatever dark matter is at the end of
the day is going to satisfy all of these
observables and you know getting there
it's going to be absolutely amazing the
and you also said something that I think
is very provocative so let's circle back
to it that you want the standard model
of particle physics to fail and this
surprises me because on the internet I
read that you know establishment
scientists are not open to new ideas and
they just want to you know prop up the
ideas they already have but you're
telling me you want your theory to fail
that sounds weird yes
so we know that we know that the
standard model that we have is
incomplete
well I already mentioned for example it
does not have a theory of neutrino
masses and you know it is it's what we
call an effective field theory so it
addresses it like a small a small Upton
like it is valid up to a certain energy
but not beyond so for example we know
that it doesn't address you know quantum
gravity in any way but even simpler in
neutrino masses so the theory is
incomplete and then when it breaks you
would have hint of what what it is that
you need to address and what it is that
you need to fix so I don't think
physicists are not open to new ideas if
anything they come up with way too many
ideas Trico
um so yeah I mean I think I everybody
wants it I think when it fails is going
to be the most exciting yeah for the
field because that's when we know oh
that's the hint these are the things
that go wrong that's what we have
missing in our theory and that's what we
need to address to be to be perfectly
honest right we were kind of hopeful
that would happen at the Large Hadron
Collider and so far it is not absolutely
so now every time you know our
experimentalist friends who show up new
plots and and they're like a Mussina
models right again and you don't hear
like aha no it is an amazing theory and
it's extremely successful and it's
incredible that it can actually make so
many predictions of so many observables
and interactions that it can explain so
beautifully but we know for a fact is
definitely not complete and it hasn't
happen in a larger Hadron Collider but
it will happen at some experiments at
some energy scale at some point it will
definitely fail and I think that would
be quite an interesting hint for physics
ya know it's a very strange situation to
be in where your theory fits all the
data and you're sure that it's wrong
right it's a little bit frustrating you
don't have any clues to as to how to
move on okay but speaking moving on so
we have some evidence that Dark Matter
exists we have some candidates for what
it could be and then I interrupted you
but you were going to tell us the
different ways we can actually
experimental e probe what the dark
matter is that's right so this we were
just talking about the Large Hadron
Collider or what we call Collider
searches that is one of the ways that we
can detect dark matter and basically you
would just you know in the these
colliders what you do is actually
collide
you know protons together and that kind
of energy builds colliding them at very
very high energies is going to produce a
lot of different particles and at some
point you might produce a dark matter so
there are a lot of these structures that
you know looking for the Dark Matter
then you might say well okay how am I
gonna see this because it doesn't
interact very much with
my with standard model particles with
the particles that I know and the way
that you would see it is actually would
be kind of beautiful because you would
see the what we call missing energy in
your detector so basically we know about
conservation of energy and conservation
of momentum so if you can if you what
you get at the end of the day is like a
stream of particles go in one way and
then nothing to balance it out on the
other side it means that you have
something that is dark but it has to be
there because of conservation of
momentum of course the catch there is
that neutrinos do that to tree nose part
but other than that that would be kind
of an interesting way of looking for
dark matter I mean it does you can see
why people in the street become a little
dubious because you're saying that
you're going to detect the existence of
dark matter by looking for missing
energy you're looking for something that
you can't see by not seeing something
else somewhere else that's right I think
it is interesting but it also kind of
balances out it's kind of like I think
okay so if you were if you were walking
by a park and then you see somebody
sitting on a seesaw with a seesaw and
then the other side is completely empty
but the seesaw is not really completely
tipped you're like huh something is
there even there the seesaw is broken or
there is some something else that I just
can't see sitting on the other side this
is kind of the same little bit of the
same logic here where there is either
your interactions are broken and the
theory is broken or there is something
else coming off on the other side that
you just didn't see and this is what you
kind of tried to figure out what else is
missing and the idea of there being
missing energy and events at a particle
accelerator that sounds like something
which we might creep up on gradually
right like rather than discovering
something and there's just a big plot
and you see the particle that you found
this is something we're just slugging
through and collecting more data and
doing this for years and years might be
the way to get it is that is that the
right way to think about it that's true
so basically what you would make is try
- kind of a lot of these methods are
based on statistics and large statistics
so what you would try to do is actually
kind of put all of these events that
look somewhat the same together and try
to see if that missing energy has you
know a common mass or you know common
properties that keep creeping up it's
not just you know a failure of your
detector that is just like I'm missing a
spot there yeah so yes a lot of it is
built on statistics especially because
there are so many events in the Large
Hadron Collider and they're going to
increase even more in the next
generation which is called LHC high
luminosity a Large Hadron Collider so I
mean it is an amazing piece of
experimental physics in general to be
able to reconstruct all of that
especially so fast but yes you need
statistics and that's why a lot of these
experiments we run them for quite long a
long time to be able to disentangle the
interesting events from what we call
background which is standard model and
it's also interesting what's on right
but it's different yes okay if we're not
lucky enough to get evidence directly in
an experiment like we build like the
Large Hadron Collider what else can we
do to look for the dark matter right so
then we can go into what we call direct
detection so you want to detect it
directly how does this work you have
huge tanks of it's actually different
material but the most common one is
really xenon so you have a huge tank of
xenon it's actually a few tons of xenon
that you put in you shake it and then
you put it very very deep underground so
for example there's one so some of the
experiments are usually like in deep in
mine shafts and everything then you have
so then your email is just sitting there
and you're waiting for one Dark Matter
particle I don't the many that might be
going through your experiment one of
them to hopefully interact by basically
you know it when it interacts with that
xenon and knocks it up just a little
that it will knock out one of its
electrons and you put the whole thing in
in an electric field and that electron
is going to kind of get
get pulled to the top of the experiment
that's what you know that whoa
something something hit there so there
are a few things here uh first why do
you need this deep underground well
because they're always backgrounds
they're always something else on my set
your experiment and in this particular
case we call these cosmic rays or cosmic
muons so there are a lot of particles
that hit the atmosphere all the time and
they make a lot of other particles like
pi ons and muons and everything and
these neons I actually like going
through us all the time because they're
coming out of an atmosphere and they
usually don't do anything even though I
recently well I recently discovered that
there is actually a whole set of
research about cosmic comedians flipping
bits in computer clusters and then they
need to correct for that which is
absolutely amazing I think they also do
sometimes cause DNA mutations oh yeah I
think III I'm not completely sure about
this but I mean cosmic rays do help your
DNA mutate so there you go the muons
they seem so innocuous and yet do a lot
of things yeah but yeah so they could
also you know hate your experiments and
then you're like oh I just covered Dark
Matter oh never mind that's why you put
your experiment very very deep
underground where all that dirt and you
know usually for them sometimes under
mountain tops and everything all these
mountains are going to absorb a lot of
these cosmic moons and they would not
interfere with your experiments right
okay and is this good for sort of all
kinds of dark matter detection or are we
looking for some kinds of dark matter
but not others so this would actually
work mainly for wimps although there are
new different new techniques that you
know instead of the xenon they would
choose different different materials
like for example helium and a lot of
semiconductors on superconductor
material and that would wear that would
help
them kind of explore mass is below the
wimps but the standard you know large
experiment like this it's going to be
mainly addressing the wimps which is the
1 to 100 GeV or Giga electron volt mass
range right oh yeah and my impression is
these experiments have started they've
been going on and they've looked like we
could have gotten lucky by now right we
could have actually seen the wimps by
now but we're nowhere near finished
looking for where they might be that's
right so a lot of people are actually
kind of getting stressed that maybe
wimps are not the way to go because yes
direct detection experiments have been
going on for a while and we've been
building bigger and better experiments I
mean it's whirling out huge you know
swathes of parameter space and the dark
matter is not there yet
and interestingly enough actually soon
the these experiments are going to be so
good that they're going to be detecting
they're hitting something that we call
the neutrino floor and they're basically
going to see neutrinos yeah instead of
the dark matter and this is incredible
because these are very very small
cross-sections that you wouldn't see
with with this type of setup actually
yet so yeah if anything we'll see solar
neutrinos again in a different
experiments so the neutrino is like
neutrinos static in your in your radio
that's right
inside just like you know that
background that when you get yeah you
you get to it and then all of a sudden
that's it's going to dominate your
background because direct detection
experiments so far have been running
pretty much background free yeah because
nothing is gonna get through you know a
mile of earth to get your experiment and
actually hit it you have to be a bit
careful about you know the material that
you're using for experiment because
sometimes some material radiates a
little bit so these have to be very very
clean and again you know my hat
experimentalist is they build amazing
things but other it's just yeah we
haven't seen Dark Matter yet and to be
honest because you know
full full disclosure here that's the
other big thing looming over us right we
haven't seen any new particles of the
Large Hadron Collider we also haven't
detected the wimps at these underground
experiments and in some sense they went
hand in hand right I mean physics
arranges itself by what the masses of
the particles are and the sort of mass
range the LHC is looking at is the same
as the mass range that the wimp
detectors are looking at and everyone
expected to see something there and we
haven't so it's a little bit of back to
the drawing board time absolutely I
think it has felt kind of the fields
with a bit of disappointment and trying
to figure out exactly how where to go
from there and what are the new
strategies I think it is kind of I think
it's a good thing to do in the sense
that it's an it's kind of more of a call
for creativity and a lot of people are
kind of adopting that like from both the
theoretical and the experimental sides
where you try to think of definitely new
theories that could explain all of these
observables because you know when you
see nothing that is an observable
because that means it's ruling out
something yeah it's not that it was
waste no it's really not so whatever
your your theory is has to actually
explain all this these null results so
you really have to be very very creative
there but also from an experimental
point of view you need to figure out new
technologies and new experiments to
probe different masses and think of
experiments that nobody else has built
before and I don't know I think all of
this kind of makes physics really really
fun even though of course we would want
something to work in the end and you
would want to discover new things of
course but really looking at physics
from a new way I think it's very
exciting but you know this is why I do
what I do
but and also just just to be fair on the
other side you know if the dark matter
is accion's we don't have a hope of
seeing them at these underground
experiments we have to use some
completely different technique right
that's right and there have been quite a
few of these experiments as well so that
it's pretty simple what you would want
to do is build halo scope so basically
you're trying to you you try to kind of
have this experiment where a next-gen is
going to to kind of make some resonance
these are actually okay differently it's
so differently these are very different
scale experiments so remember we're
talking about like multiple tons of
xenon these are actually a lot smaller
and the axioms are going going to get
into the experiments and actually make a
magnetic electromagnetic field that you
would rather that you would detect so
something yeah
which is a completely different set of
experiment in this a different
completely different mechanism and they
have been kind of doing quite a good job
at rolling out different parameter space
of course again in different masses of
possible accion's but that space is very
very large ya know my impression is that
unlike the WIMP case where we really
have ruled out a noticeable fraction of
the parameter space in the acción case
there's still a lot of room to be
explored absolutely because these
experiments are very difficult and
you're kind of tracking very very small
maths basically math windows very very
thin ones at every time that you're
running your experiment unlike you know
these wimp indirect detection where you
can pull out a huge part of the
parameter space all at once yes and so
the last thing that you mentioned was
indirect detection so if you can't
detect them indirect they can't detect
them directly why not try it indirectly
yeah that's right
so indirect detection it has a funny
name but it basically means that dark
matter is going to either annihilate or
decay into particles that we already
know and then we see those particles so
we said another way you can imagine that
the dark matter
just annihilates at the center of the
galaxy into you know electrons positrons
neutrinos gamma rays all of the above I
and then what you would see is from your
gamma-ray telescope for example is that
there is an excess of gamma rays coming
from the center of the galaxy that you
just can't explain here like wait I
expected a lot lower number of these
gamma rays why am I seeing that money
that could be a dark matter of course it
also could be astrophysics as we've
learned I think therefore the people in
the street you have to explain what that
means of course it could be astrophysics
this is all astrophysics that's true so
when we think yeah I think we already
know but not really so so okay so
basically back in 20 well it started in
2009 where so there is this telescopes
close Fermi telescope and it basically
measures the gamma rays in the sky and
in 2009 was the first evidence that
there was a little bit more gamma rays
from in the range of masses from 1 to 3
GB or so in the center of the galaxy
then uh with more data and as we talked
about earlier you gather more statistics
sorry I need to interrupt here too
because I think we're doing another
physicists shortcut because you said
gamma rays in the range of masses around
1 GeV or whatever but of course the
gamma rays are photons and they're
massless but you're using e equals
mc-squared right that's right energies
that you would get by annihilating a
particle with a mass of that much yes
exactly
so in yeah I'm physics I think your
first day in grad school they tell you
equals MC squared and C equals 1 and
then just go there and you kind of never
go back but yes the protons are need
mass massless but these are kind of
equivalent energy that they would have
absolutely based on that relation yes so
and then in 2014 we're gathering more
and more sistex there was even more
evidence that there is some excess there
that ended up being called the galactic
center excess so
why is the galactic center actually
interesting at all
well you would expect within what our
current theories of dark matter you
would expect that there is a much higher
density of dark matter in the center of
the galaxy so you can think of it as
like a deep potential well that your gas
the stars are kind of like falling into
and so if you were if the dark matter
was to annihilate or decay or do
something it would be where there is the
most of it which is at the center of the
galaxy so this so far was consistent
then yeah so then there is this excess
of gamma rays that we try to figure out
and we were like okay oh that would be
interesting is that really dark matter
the first thing that you check for
example is what is the spatial
distribution of these stars which means
that all of these gamma rays which means
is my signal coming from everywhere in
the galactic center or is it you know
correlated with the Stars and the disk
does it have like a shape of some sort
hmm is you we didn't expect the Dark
Matter to have some weird
the first Destin ended up that the
signal was isotropic which means that
it's really uniform coming from the sky
so that's cool then you're like ooh that
might really be Dark Matter that's
interesting but then you try to think of
what else could it be which is usually
and and this is the toughest part with
indirect detection because you always
have to say what else could it be
yeah then the other competing theory it
could be that you have a lot of pulsars
which are just these neutron stars that
just turn really fast and they're
emitting a lot of these gamma rays that
you don't see otherwise that you
wouldn't have seen detected previously
and then the question is okay is it
pulsars is a dark matter and you have to
you know estimate how many pulsars you
have but it's in the center of the
galaxy which is you know pretty far so
and based on a lot of things that you
don't know so yeah so I think that was
the status of it right now is that it
might be it's probably mostly pulsars I
almost burned yeah it's it's kind of
yeah so we need to we need to at least
see some of these
sar so the way you would do it is by
seeing it in radio telescopes but you
can't really see huge parts of the sky
all at once a radio telescope so yeah
this is the fun of physics trying to
figure out it's investigative work I
mean because it does make sense in
retrospect right I mean you are hoping
to see signals of dark matter at the
center of the galaxy because that's
where you should have a high density of
dark matter but also there's a high
density of other weird stuff at the
center of the galaxy and we're realizing
we were not quite as careful as we could
have been figuring out what the signals
should be from that other weird stuff
that is weird but not nearly as weird as
Dark Matter that's exactly right and so
then you can go for you know option B
okay what if the galaxy is the galactic
center is too messy where else can I see
it and then you might be able to say
something about norm galaxies so what
are these
yeah we have so we have our galaxy the
Milky Way and we are sitting pretty much
with the edge of a disc of the Milky Way
but Milky Way is actually much larger
and it's we're swimming in what we call
the Dark Matter halo
so it basically a sphere of dark matter
more or less that you can think about
anyway so it has a lot of gravitational
pull because it is a pretty big galaxy
and because of this gravitational pull
it also pulled smaller galaxies very
close to it and these are kind of like
satellite galaxies it's the same way
that you know the the moon at the
satellite of the earth more or less oh
we have that we have this Milky Way it
has its own small satellites its own
that we called dwarf galaxies which are
galaxies were a lot smaller anyway so
these smaller galaxies have a lot less
baryons or a lot less stars and gas than
the center of the galaxy which means
that if you see signal from them it's
probably actually coming out of the dark
matter so they have more what we call
the mass to light ratio they have a lot
of mass coming from dark matter and very
little light coming from stars
unlike the Milky Way that has a pretty
high Massa light ratio I'm pretty low
so we think that in dwarf galaxies
there's less chance we'd be confused by
pulsars or other crazy things
that's exactly right the problem is that
there's much smaller so they have a lot
lesser matter rate so what we can do and
what we do is we can stack them so
basically try to get for example the
gamma rays from a lot of these dwarf
galaxies and put them together on top of
each other stack them and try to see is
there something significant there do we
really see in excess of dark matter and
then so the status of things is that
there was one dwarf galaxy that might
have had an excess of nothing confirmed
and a lot of my current work is trying
to better understand how much dark
matter should we expect in these
galaxies because it's a very difficult
measurement that we have to do so yeah
there is a lot to be done so okay but I
mean this is this is good for the people
listening I mean you have some data so
is that is the constraint that you don't
have enough data of gamma rays from
these dwarf galaxies yet or that we
haven't analyzed them carefully enough
or that we don't understand the
background astrophysics so we have a lot
of data here is just that so it's not
about the background of astrophysics
because you'd expect that to be small
it's basically how much dark matter do
you expect and or galaxies all together
and that's a very tough kind of
measurement or measurement between
quotes that you have to make the same
way how much dark matter there is at the
center of the galaxy is still a big
question we have so let's focus on door
galaxies because they're a bit simpler
how would you know how much dark matter
there is in a galaxy like that well the
only measurement that we have is really
based on the motion of stars so in this
is not 3d motion so I don't really see
all the directions of motion of these
stars all I see is what we call the
line-of-sight velocity but basically is
the it's basically the Doppler shift is
that star going
wait for me or is it coming towards me
and with what velocity so I can make
those measurements about few stars
usually just the bright ones so not all
of them of these objects and then have
some understanding about okay these
stars are moving within a certain speed
what is the amount of mass that would
give me that would be consistent with
such a speed so the thing is there are a
lot of things that could go wrong there
basically you don't know since you're
only seeing one direction of the motion
of stars basically is it coming towards
me or away from me you don't know the
sideway motion it's hard to tell you
have kind of like missing information
like it's sideway motion could be very
large or very small and you wouldn't
know so you don't really know like the
full velocity of that so it's hard to
gonna get them full mass you of course
have to assume that the system is in
equilibrium basically that means that
there is nothing weird happening to your
stars they're not getting pulled or
pushed by something else I mean in in
particular for example the gravitational
field at the Milky Way it's not doing
anything to them you have to assume that
the whole thing is the sphere it doesn't
have to be kinda goes back to the joke
of the spherical cow in fact no galaxy
okay good yes that's right
so there are a lot of so we know some
something about the mass of these
objects but we need to know them much
much better to be able to say do rule
things out or rule things in with much
more confidence and so what are the what
are the prospects what's gonna happen I
mean for one thing you mentioned the
Fermi gamma-ray telescope tell us about
that it's in space right this is it's
hard to build a gamma-ray telescope here
on earth but it is possible that's right
so the the this is a gamma-ray telescope
that is in space and the reason that
it's much more difficult to have these
things on earth is because the
atmosphere is really really painful to
get through so for earth-like
experiments you can actually do get some
gamma rays but a very very high energies
and they are you know these what we call
like terekhov telescopes so basically
these telescopes in the desert of I
think some of them are in the desert in
Africa and basically what they have is a
gamma ray that is very very energetic
comes in and then of course it interacts
and makes a shower of particles that was
the experiment and they end up moving in
the medium of the experiment usually
water faster than the speed of water
speed of light in water nothing goes
faster than the speed of light in vacuum
but it actually can happen that's right
and that's but yes the prospect of so
Fermi has gathered a lot of amazing data
and actually you know it has given us
for example catalogs what we call like
the the memory catalogs of a lot of
things that are in the Milky Way and
even a bit further that actually emit
gamma rays so it is definitely a great
way to understand you know the
astrophysics of the Milky Way
another experiment and the Milky Way and
its surroundings but the reason that I
think the world of astrophysics so as
for particle physics is really really
interesting and in in it for a ride is
of all the experiments and all the
telescopes that are gonna come in online
and have come in online so there are
there is the Vera Rubin telescope called
unless the C is coming in 2023 there are
other upgrades of current experiments
but the one I'm most excited about and a
lot of my work is on is called Gaia and
Gotha is this space telescope that was
launched in December 2013 with a goal of
giving us the the positional
measurements so the sideway motion and
distances of 1 billion stars and this is
one percent of the Milky Way yes
so this is so wait so yeah I mean since
you're younger than me you forget but
when I was your age we were excited
about the Hipparchus satellite and this
was a satellite that was gonna get I
guess thousands of
stars their distances and their sideways
motions that's right so Hipparchus ran
from 89 to 93 and it was very exciting
but it's amazing when you see you know
the the map of how much Gaia covers now
compared to Hipparchus and yeah a lot of
people get offended they're like
Hipparchus was a great I'm not saying
anything else but guy is amazing - yeah
but but just to see how amazing it is I
mean it's really hard to know how far
away stars are right you can see where
they are in the sky but it's this
amazing technological achievement to
also measure the distances to a billion
stars absolutely there sideway motion
really now you can for the first time
you can actually have 3d maps of to be
to be there now it's still just the
closest stars but form but it's
absolutely incredible the way that what
the amount of data that we're getting so
the second data release of Gaia was back
in April 2018 almost two years ago from
April 20 and we and we got so one
billion stars there you know their
distances and their sideway motion that
we call proper motion but a subset of
them we also had the line-of-sight
velocity that I talked about earlier so
so for a subset a very small subset of
seven million stars
we actually have 60 kinematics it's
absolutely incredible in the it's a it's
an amazing kind of it's an amazing data
set that you can get so much out of and
indeed we did back in 2018 a new murder
of stars has been discovered
based on the motion of stars so let me
explain what mergers are basically
remember earlier I said that we have
these satellites because like gravity
that you know the Milky Way is kind of
pulling a lot of these small satellites
into it huh well these satellites they
have you know stars and dark matter but
sometimes they crash into us and we pull
them quite fast so they would just
completely get completely disrupted so
they're completely destroyed and get
mixed up with the Milky Way
so the
discovery of 2018 is that there is such
a merger that has happened somewhere
between six and ten billion years ago
and smashed into our galaxy brought in
so many stars with us and and it's
interesting because it's a it's a pretty
big object it's math with somewhere
between one and ten percents the mass of
the Milky Way and we never knew it was
there until we actually finally had the
kinematic data for it it has a very
unfortunate name because of the person
who first saw it called it the Gaia
sausage because it is roughly sausage
shaped after being it is extended yes
but we still give that person hell every
time okay the sausage yeah I mean Gaia
just seems like you know Greek mythology
very highbrow and then was like making
the sausage okay that's right
he's an incredible business and he saw
and he saw the shape you know sausage
eat so he was that with that name after
the fact that was a there were attempts
like calling it the Gaia Enceladus and
the solidus is a Greek gods fun of Gaia
yeah it's amazing
but it's unfortunate everybody will
remember only the sausage so so so what
we learn about dark matter from seeing
this sausage shaped collection of stars
that has been cannibalized by the Milky
Way that's right so that's where what I
do comes in a lot of the things that
I've been doing is trying to understand
how much dark matter would come from
these murders and answer the question
can I understand how fast the dark
matter is going based on the speed of
these stars when they merge in hmm so
what I do is actually use simulations a
lot of them a part actually developed
here at Caltech from Phil Hopkins group
and these simulations are called fire
which actually is an acronym for
feedback in a realistic environment but
the reason that it's really cool is
because we can make a
a lot of fire puns the titles of our
paper oh this is just the worst there's
no pun they could not possibly resist I
know we just like so yeah what I did is
actually I used a lot of these
simulations so these simulations
actually simulate what building a galaxy
just like the Milky Way it's really
really cool so what you do is like you
start there really really early times
you have your dark matter particles and
you teach them gravity and then you also
add in and beauty of the fire group
exact you know the physics that has been
brought in by the fire group is to add
add a lot of these physics of you know
the gas interactions on the stars etc on
top of that and then you let that you
just like teaching different
interactions and you just let that
evolve for very early on and at the end
of the day 13 billion years later you
end up with a galaxy that looks very
much like the Milky Way it's not exactly
the same obviously it is it has the same
properties in the sense that you end up
with a nice just galaxy it has a proper
mass etc and this is absolutely
incredible the cool thing about these
simulations and the reason that I really
love using them is that I know that I
can track the Stars and I can track the
Dark Matter
basically particle by particle to figure
out exactly what's going to land in you
know the Sun or the position of where my
where the Sun is would be in the
simulations and then figure out if there
are correlations between if there are
any relationship between the dark matter
and the stars and where they came from
etc and what would I expect to see in my
experiments today and when you say just
to be clear when you say you can track
every particle this is not like
elementary particles like protons this
is the particle in the simulation that
is used to model a whole bunch of mass
that's right so unfortunately we cannot
just like simulate the whole galaxy up
to its so what we do is that we we call
these particles in our
ulation but these are actually like you
know huge clumps of dark matter and
clumps of stars so for example the stars
and the the star is what we call one
star and simulations it really has 7000
solar masses so it's basically about
seven thousand stars pumped up together
because that's where the resolution yeah
it's a it's a low resolution version of
the galaxy that I think that makes
perfect sense in our modern video gaming
here people know what that means
exactly yeah but the nice thing then is
we can really appreciate the fact that
since we do believe in dark matter since
it's not just modified gravity the dark
matter is located somewhere and the
distribution is kind of lumpy and has
structure and is interesting for better
and for worse right absolutely I think
it's really really fun because it you
know it plays into it is kind of the way
that the reason that I do this is
because it plays into the experiments
that we were discussing earlier so you
know the lumpiness of dark matter it
means that you might have you know an
excess of gamma rays coming from those
lumpiness or if the dark matter is
faster or slower that would affect how
many of them you would see in direct
detection experiments you know in the
tanks of xenon underground because the
faster the Dark Matter the more energy
it might deposit from the xenon so it
all is very much correlated at large at
these very different scales which I find
absolutely fascinating because the
theory of dark matter really at its
essence is you know a theory of
astrophysics and very large scales but
also particle physics and the smallest
scales yeah and everything to make sense
and I about all day so I mean what what
have we learned so but by knowing that
there is this sausage there there's
other structures or whatever what are
the implications for trying to detect
the dark matter and and finally finding
it that's right so basically what we try
and do trying to extrapolate the dark
matter velocity for example based on the
star and the velocity of the stars from
the guys sausage one thing we found out
that it might actually this the stars
might be going there were
the stars and and then consequently the
Dark Matter might be going a bit slower
than we would expect which means that we
might have been ruling out more
parameter space and saying that oh this
Dark Matter cannot be this more than we
should have so we kind of have to kind
of go back and really address all of
these you know all of these differences
and making sure that our initial models
that are not really empirical there are
just based on assuming that the dark
that the Milky Way is relaxed and
everything is fine we realize that no
the Milky Way has quite more interesting
structure than we saw before and we need
to take that into account in our
experiments one thing that is quite
interesting that I found last year with
my amazing collaborator Brian off stick
who is a postdoc at Harvard basically he
was trying to so he was building this
machine learning methods trying to
figure out which stars did not come from
the Milky Way and this was absolutely
amazing so then he built this wonderful
catalog and then he sent it to me he was
like I don't know what I'm looking at
this is the star Catholics are like
sorry the Stars just have fun I was like
this is gonna be great so then the first
thing that you do really when you get a
catalog or any dataset is that you start
calling it and you just make random
plots and figure out does it look like
expected - does it not I'll take your
wonderful do use data anyway I started
plotting me isn't you know the guy a
sausage was there just there it would
have me having to look for it I was like
this is amazing but then there was like
this closet clump of stars that was not
supposed to be there and you know when
when you're young and you're watching
movies and everything you just think
that oh yeah if I see something amazing
I'm gonna have my Eureka moment oh my
gosh
is incredible but then you go to grad
school and you realize that every moment
like that is just a bug in your no no
there's so many here at the moment it
didn't quite see the light of day it's
your exactly so of course as a
well-trained failed good shooting there
was the first thing that kind of came to
mind
so I said only for three weeks and it
didn't tell any of my collaborators I
was plotting it every which way but then
I realized no it's actually it might not
be a bargains actually might be
something which is really cool and then
you have to actually check against
literature and you're like oh it might
be something that somebody else has
already found in which case that's
pointless sure um thankfully nobody else
has found that one so I got to name it
which is really cool this is cool
it's called NYX NYX for Greek goddess of
the night but I thought it was petunia
t-fitting here but what can we learn
from this
so NYX is that this it's the cup of
stars that are rotating with the Sun
like it's these are stores are very
close
they're co-rotating but they also kind
of have this wave of movement towards
the the center of the galaxy which is
very bizarre because you don't expect
them to do that so then there are these
two these two theories that we could
think of that would explain this either
something hit the Milky Way and kind of
caused these waves and these stars are
kind of getting pushed just because you
know imagine you you just if you have a
lake and you're throwing a rock in it
and then it's gonna cause waves how
stars are just moving that way or it's
an it's a merger just like the sausage
so it's another object that just fell
into the Milky Way and these stars that
I see here are actually remnant of this
murder the interesting thing is that if
it is indeed a murder it might have also
brought in with it a lot of dark matter
that would have formed something called
the dark disk so something that is kind
of co-rotating with us and that would
change you know our estimates of direct
detection and detection quite a lot
actually so we're still trying to figure
out what it is but if any it but it's
definitely really fun
so this is something that I get confused
about so maybe help the audience with in
some sense we hope that there is less
dark matter near us than we think
because we we have a certain threshold
that we've ruled out right of a number
of events in our detectors etc and if
there's more dark matter than we think
that means that the parameter space is
even lower right the parameter space is
even is even more constrained by our
experiments so there's more wiggle room
if there's less dark matter around is
that the way it goes
did I get it right so so if if dark
matter is a lot less than a lot of more
of our theories are still possible yes
however if the dark matter for example
is the dark matter coming is coming out
of a dark disk so if it has a
non-trivial velocity distribution then
the shape of those limits that we see in
the literature is actually quite
different because this you know this new
structure is going to affect very high
masses but it's not going to affect low
mass dark matter so you know usually
like these flaws that we're ruling out
might actually look quite different so
it's not just it's not just like an
overall scaling it's not just Oh more of
it or less of it is going to be ruled
out it's just that the shape so the max
versus the probability that would detect
it might look quite different which
would be very interesting okay so Gaia B
because it's given us this 3d map of a
billion stars is helping us figure out
this interplay between the location of
dark matter in the galaxy and our
ability to constrain its properties here
on earth that's right so the three it
only has a billion stars basically with
proper motion so the the sideway motion
and the parallax it's only a subset of
seven million of them that has 3d
velocities but for the third data
release of Gaia which is scheduled for
next year with some delay now but we're
going to go from that seven million up
to 100 250 million so it's going to be
amazing whatever we're gonna get
so yeah so we can do that we can also do
so it's not the only thing that we can
get out of Gaia there are what we call
in the process of pulling these
satellites they end up forming streams
in the sky so basically stars are kind
of almost aligned and using Gaia for
example we can actually see gaps in
these streams and there is one of these
streams I called it's called Gd one that
has a couple of gaps and then the
question is how do you explain gaps and
these streams yeah in one of these
theories is that if you have a clump of
dark matter that just goes right through
your stream and pulls a lot of stars
with it
then that means that that's how you
would get one of these gaps in your
stream which we can see with Gaia and
the question is how big is a clump of
what is it how fast it was going etc
really helps you narrow down the theory
of dark matter that you have because
some theories of dark matter for example
would not have very low mass clumps and
if you see a very low mass companies
that that theory is not right is that so
sorry what kind of theories of dark
matter would not have low mass clumps so
something that we called warm dark
matter
mm-hm and even theories of self
interacting dark matter but let's figure
some of the warm warm dark matter so
remember earlier when I said that
neutrinos are go too fast so they
destroy a lot of the a lot of the
structure that they have so instead of
having something as hot as neutrinos if
you have your dark matter that is a bit
warm which means that it's going a
little bit too fast but not extremely
fast yeah
then it will destroy very small like
very very small galaxies or sound like
galaxies just by going through them and
puncturing them and basically heating up
the system is what we call it and that's
for business but um but it's not gonna
make much of a difference to larger
objects so which means that these
theories are not going to allow small
enough clumps that's right yeah cutting
the power spectrum so yeah
so then the question is the gaps that
you see are they consistent with very
very small clumps and if so that would
rule out modal's of form dark matter for
example got it okay good yeah all right
so there's basically this very exciting
frontier set of prospects about you know
the new data coming in and teaching us
about dark matter even before we can
directly detect it but therefore I feel
like you know we've done our duty and we
can let our hair down a little bit now
you already mentioned that the idea of
self interacting Dark Matter I mean all
this dark matter stuff that you've been
talking about all the ideas for it
had roughly speaking been that the dark
matter is just there you know it might
be different places or might be
different densities might be different
velocities but it doesn't do anything
other than move under the force of
gravity but now you're you're
introducing the possibility that the
dark matter could be more interesting it
could interact with itself or or dark
energy or something or ordinary matter
in interesting ways that's right it
could it could have its own self
interactions along with any interaction
that it might have for with the senior
model with our particles so one thing
that you know is a particle physicists
nightmare is that what if dark matter
does not interact with us at all right
how can we possibly see it well if it
has its own self interaction which means
that yes it interacts with gravity
that's a given with dark matter but what
if it interacts with each other like -
dark matter particles you know they
bounce off each other or the scatter of
each other annihilate into you know more
dark matter etc what would we see well
interestingly if that happens it means
that the the higher density point so the
center of or galaxies or the center of
the Milky Way is going to be a lot less
dense and the reason for it is because
if there is a high density spot and
they're interacting too much they will
kind of kick each other out and that
would drop the density of that of that
part this is what we call the core
cusp so from simulations you would
expect to have a cusp in the density of
dark matter which means that the profile
so which means that the profile is like
very very steep that there is a lot of
dark matter in the middle of galaxies
and in particular dwarf galaxies uh but
if you add in South interaction that
cusp becomes a core which means that
instead of just sharp going sharply very
very high as you go to smaller smaller
distances from the center it's going to
just like become you know more or less a
constant or stable okay um so a little
smushed out a little bit more fluffy
exactly so that would be kind of a probe
of seeing that Dark Matter is indeed
there and has some kind of properties
even though it doesn't interact with you
know the electrons and the protons etc
so you would see it from what we call
from astrophysics or Astrophysical
probes do we have some you know
pre-existing feeling for whether or not
we should expect the Dark Matter to have
inter interesting interactions with
itself or is it just easier I know this
is sort of a only quasi scientific
question right it's like our feelings
rather than what we can observe but you
know we do have Bayesian priors on what
we expect do you think the Dark Matter
interacts with itself in interesting
ways well I think it's very unlikely
it's very likely the dark matter is just
that one particle that has like that one
interaction way too simple especially
giving them how complex our standard
model is I would expect them the dark
matter sector and it's a whole sector
it's not just one particle for example
is going to be complex it's going to
have very interesting interactions etc
so yeah I mean I think I would not be
surprised if the Dark Matter has you
know some kind of self interaction and
if it's a very rich sector in general
than what we have I would be very
surprised it was just one I asked in
part because I honestly don't know
myself you know I written papers about
interesting ideas for dark matter in
one on dark electromagnetism where you
can have dark magnetic fields and maybe
even dark atoms and dark chemistry and
things like that
but I just don't know if it's more
likely that it should be that way
because there's a million different ways
you could have interesting dark matter
sectors or less likely because it's just
an ugly complication that doesn't
actually solve any puzzles yeah
interesting question and and I think
it's one of those things that it's good
if people think differently because they
will yeah and time doing different
things but yeah they I mean
rationally there is no AA priori
information about this at all right so
it's something that we need to do kind
of track I I think I would be very
surprised if it's very simple but that's
just know like you said it's good the
different people have different
intuitions about this because ultimately
we're gonna find out by you know doing
the experiment and we're gonna figure it
out and I think that you've given us
today a lot more reason to be optimistic
that we will figure out I think don't
know correct me if I'm wrong but your
enthusiasm is contagious I think that
I'm excited about the prospect for
learning more and more about dark matter
in the near future
I tend to be very optimistic about this
well my job bye
yeah I know people were a little bit
less optimistic so this is the most
optimism you guys good yeah yeah that's
the right person of you on the podcast
even innocent thanks so much for being
on the mindscape podcast thank you thank
you
[Music]
you
[Music]